deux syndicats demandent la fermeture du
commissariat de cannes dans les alpes
maritimes une campagne de dépistage
massif a été mené dans le commissariat
et sur 200 agents 42 ont été dépistés
positifs aux copies de 19 soit 20% des
effectifs
à l'aller le syndicat de police des
alpes-maritimes demande la fermeture de
l'hôtel de police cannois et il
s'inquiète aussi du fait que certains de
leurs collègues ne présentait aucun
symptôme
la grande difficulté c'est que il ya des
collègues qui effectivement des
symptômes mais il ya d'autres collègues
qui ne manifestait absolument aucun
symptôme
d'où notre souhait et notre
revendication à nous unité sgp police
062 mètres en 14 n de faire fermer pour
14 jours
le commissariat de cannes l'idée étant
bien entendu d'isoler les porter des
noms porter parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
des collègues qui sont dépistés qui sont
négatifs mais rien ne nous dit que dans
trois jours parce qu'au contact de
porteurs sains ceux là mêmes ne seront
pas positif
donc on est dans l'incapacité
aujourd'hui si vous voulez d'avoir de
réelles perspectives et pour avoir
discuté avec de nombreux médecins avec
des biologistes et bien il en ressort
que dans l'idéal est bien il faudrait
fermer ce commissariat alors on a en
même temps conscience que faire fermer
un commissariat en terme de logistique
c'est pas simple l'image renvoyée n'est
pas simple c'est vrai mais il appartient
à l'administration de trouver des
solutions
ce qui nous importe à nous c'est la
sécurité et la santé de nos collègues et
en l'état on a le sentiment qu'elle est
pas complètement prison